hey guys it's Wednesday I'm Dan and in
lieu of Jess McDonald not being here
this little sister from Bioshock with an
arm that's coming off is going to help
me out with games what news today let's
get into it
first up banjo kazooie spiritual
successor ukulele is finally coming to
Nintendo switch you can play the 3d
platformer starring a chameleon and bat
in bed on a boat or wherever good times
I had via the switch come December 14th
originally announced for the Wii U
alongside the ps4 Xbox one and PC
versions ukulele was cancelled for that
system and then announced for the switch
the developer platonic games have
spooked the portable version saying
they've spent many months optimizing the
game with help from Nintendo and unity
and that they're delivering a version
Nintendo fans can be proud of the switch
version of ukulele will be a little
different from its predecessors with a
custom achievement system and the
ability to play all eight minigames with
a single joy con if you're keen you can
pre-purchase ukulele from the eShop from
December 7th thanks to the ever reliable
source of video game news those good old
leaks we now know what to expect from
Call of Duty World War 2 a little bit
down the line a video posted on YouTube
which has since been pulled shows the
classic gun game multiplayer mode as
well as infected control and lockdown
gun game is a personal favorite of mine
and tasks you with getting a kill with a
range of different weapons it's great
there's also a glimpse of two new guns
the girl 43 rifle and Sten submachine
gun there's no word on when we can
expect the new content to arrive or what
form they will be released in Call of
Duty World War 2 launched earlier this
month and set a new digital day one
sales record on PlayStation 4 it's also
pretty fun but I do miss my exosuit
movement finally Bungie has come under
fire after a previously undisclosed XP
scaling system was uncovered in destiny
to settle in this one's got a bunch of
graphs so it all started with a post on
reddit by user energizer X who decided
to do a little research after a bunch of
gametime energized rx collated their
data into some graphs see and found that
destiny 2 constrains the XP earned in
some situations basically if you're
earning xp to quickly post level 20 the
game will reduce your progress this is a
particular note because once you hit
level 20 each level earned is a new
bright Engram which is destiny two's
version of a cosmetic loot crate which
can also be bought for real-world money
why'd you address the findings over the
Thanksgiving break with a post on
bungie.net saying that after reviewing
some data the system is not working as
intended and has been turned off but
don't celebrate too quickly the total
XP required to level up post level 20
has been raised from 80,000 to 160,000
so while players will earn the full
amount of XP owed via events in the lake
double the amount is now required to get
a chance at getting that sweet purple
Sparrow with the spears on it in their
statement Bungie has pledged to monitor
the new system over the next week and
that any changes will be communicated
via their official channels interesting
stuff this one and definitely something
to keep an eye on that's everything I
have for you today do let me know what
you care about in the comment box below
and Jess will be back tomorrow and I
will be here as well so we'll see you
then
let me give you some advice for free
don't go out drinking on a Tuesday night
homeboy also don't drink wine I don't
understand how adults drink wine what
adults drink wine who are talking to